the announcement came in a presidential
tweet
calling it a historic breakthrough and a
massive breakthrough for peace in the
middle east
morocco and israel agreeing to full
diplomatic relations
it's another victory for the israeli
prime minister morocco follows the uae
bahrain and sudan in recognizing israel
in establishing full diplomatic
relations
this is the foundation on which we can
now build this peace will
resume liaison officers quickly between
israel and morocco
and work as rapidly as possible to
establish full diplomatic relations
we'll also institute direct flights
between morocco and israel
and israel and morocco giving this
bridge of peace
an even more solid foundation this will
be a very warm piece
in return the trump administration has
gone against decades of u.s policy
and agreed to recognize the disputed
western sahara region as moroccan
western sahara has been disputed for
decades between morocco and the
pro-independence polisario front
they're the first country in the world
uh to recognize the moroccan claim that
there were 65 countries that were
leaning towards a future recognition
of the moroccan claim and siding with
the morocco but only the united states
has recognized the claim
uh leapfrogging ahead of the u.n process
which has been going on for
a long time now and sidelining the
international law um concerns the
population the sahara the population of
the palestinians all of that has been
sidelined
in order to get this deal done before
the trump administration goes
the palestinians have condemned the
agreement saying it's yet another
country to break a promise of not
recognizing israel
until the establishment of a palestinian
state but more and more arab countries
are establishing ties with israel
whereas the reality of a palestinian
state seems to fade
further and further away it's hailed as
yet another victory for israel
another unilateral move by this outgoing
administration
who have little more than a month left
in office stephanie decker al jazeera